[Music]
as in most sciences especially the human
sciences almost every major question is
open so for example the take the
question of the two obvious questions
one is how come there are any languages
at all I mean a a second question is why
are there apparently so many these are
pretty elementary questions but they're
sensible questions roughly say a hundred
thousand years ago which is almost
nothing at evolutionary time the
questions couldn't be raised because
there weren't any languages maybe two
hundred thousand but roughly that area
so it's a sensible question one is the
question how did languages suddenly
emerge in the evolutionary record and
it's pretty sudden by an evolutionary
framework you know of time involved and
then how come they proliferated how come
there isn't just one well there's steps
towards answering that there's progress
I think my own view I should say is
pretty Socratic it's not widely held but
I think we understand enough about the
fundamental computational basis of
language to see that to develop a not a
plausible scenario for how there might
have been a reasonably sudden emergence
of the fundamental nature of language
and also of why the apparent diversity
is pretty superficial so that if say a
Martian was looking at humans the way
that we look at say frogs the Martian
might conclude that this is
fundamentally one language with minor
deviations and I think we're moving
towards an understanding of how that
might be the case and it is pretty clear
that it has to be the case the time of
development is much too shallow for
fundamental changes to taking place and
we know of no fundamental changes so a
child from a hunter-gatherer tribe in
Stone Age tribe and say the Amazon
brought to Cambridge and raised here
we'll go on become a quantum physics
physicist at MIT there's no known
differences in relevant cognitive
capacities so there's something
fundamentally the same about all of us
and it's whatever emerged pretty
recently and we have to work out the to
show that the enormous apparent variety
is a kind of superficial variation and
also to explain how it might have
suddenly appeared in the evolutionary
record
[Music]